c'est le premier maire saint quentinois
à rejoindre le parti des manuels macron
stéphane mirambeau a rendu public son
adhésion à la république en marche un
ralliement effectif depuis avril 2017
mais le maire de villepreux a choisi
délibérément son timing
j'ai attendu d'officialiser son
ralliement à un moment particulier
certains me disaient qu'il ne fallait
pas le faire parce qu emmanuel macron
baisser dans les sondages moi je pense
justement que c'est au contraire c'est
dans ces moments là qu'il faut soutenir
l'action du gouvernement est un
véritable relais expliqué qu'il faut une
europe forte et ne pas justement
défendre le repli sur soi comme
certaines listes vont sûrement le faire
la deuxième raison je veux soutenir
emmanuel macron dans ses réformes je le
pays mérite vraiment et a besoin d'être
réformé maires de villes pro depuis 2008
sur une liste divers droite réélu en
2014 dès le premier tour avec plus de
63% des voix
stéphane mirambeau suit les valeurs
d'une droite humaniste sociale est
ouverte
membre de la majorité de saint quentin
en yvelines il est vice président en
charge du budget sous une présidence de
rassemblement voulue par jean michel
fourgous
moi je dirais écouter dans la mesure où
ou
il ne met pas en cause la majorité
voilà moi il peut garder son poste faut
quand même que nos élus se sentent très
libre et vous savez j'ai toujours les
gens qui m'ont suivi moi ils me suivent
pas par soumission ils me suivent par
adhésion prochaine étape pour stéphane
mirambeau le soutien de la liste
lrm pour les européennes avant de
s'engager pleinement dans sa candidature
pour les élections municipales en 2020